so christmas morning
right you hear about this explosion and
you know the first time you read the
story or hear about it
you know the first thing you think is
hopefully not anybody was killed and
nobody was i mean
it's a minor miracle that nobody
actually was killed in this so then they
stop right thumbs up and a shout out to
those six cops and evacuated everything
and the the the two very big cops at the
end that split to the end of the streets
and kept all the patrol cars back thumbs
up to them
all those first responders learnings
from everything in america and nobody
else got hurt praise god you know what
and we will never
hear the full story of the heroic
efforts of these cops
when they heard that recorded message on
this rv saying
if you hear this message evacuate if you
hear this message
they were knocking on doors saving lives
six cops
and you know in the year of defund the
police the year thankfully ends
with us understanding just how important
they are i mean this is such a joke
anybody that still believes
in the defund the police movement
especially when you see the murder rates
that have gone up minneapolis murder
rate is up 74
over last year dallas is up dallas is up
shootings insane how much they're up i
mean when you start peeling back and
look at the number of cops that are
taking early retirement man
it's going to scare you for what's going
on in the future but kudos to those law
enforcement officers in nashville it was
unbelievable so then you start learning
more about this nut job right you
automatically assume what's this guy's
problem what's he trying to do yeah
today a story comes out that you know
now all the neighbors are gonna start
talking yesterday one of the neighbors
that talked to him at the mailbox said
oh yeah he i was gonna say that
everybody's gonna know my name in a few
days
today one of his old friends was saying
that he was a pot-smoking cop-hating
kind of oddball weirdo so he has to be
weird the other
interesting backstories about this guy
is he was sued by his own mother
over these two pieces of property that
he deeded
to this woman this 29 year old executive
in the entertainment industry she works
at
aeg in los angeles she now has two of
the houses
one of the which warner was living in
warner is the name of the suspect
so it blows up this entire street
right this rv explodes and then you're
thinking why this street and then you
know it's
it's looking like the target was this a
t building yeah
which was on that second street in in
nashville not just any building
and the right massive regional switch
center yes so you know
uh cell phone services down throughout
multiple states in the area including
nashville the flooding
you know from from this explosion led to
the the services being outaged
but you know you're going to see some
other stories now maybe some conspiracy
theories or people that are you know
looking into this thing a little bit
deeper but
one of the things that that att control
operations
headquarter thing did there on 2nd
street was have something to do with
the compilation of the voting in georgia
all right so there is some sort of
connection between
a t and that building in nashville and
what's going on as far as tabulations
and
and data and things that are happening
regarding the election in georgia the
senate runoff so
um you know and then and then did you
hear that
you know later in the day they found
another van in tennessee that was
recording to say or playing the
type of recorded message but they over
have over 100 atf and fbi agents on this
thing we're going to learn a lot more
about this a lot
a lot uh you know sooner here but this
guy was an oddball
uh he apparently was paranoid about 5g
technology
so yep you know it only makes sense that
the a t
building was what he was going after tom
i i i think this shows you kind of
the dark side of passion
you know they're you know and the riots
we saw this summer was a dark side of
passion
and you know it it really disappoints me
to see what's happening
in america when you see people like this
that are just
you know stepping up and doing it it
just kind of flipped me out question
becomes
can can these events be prevented can
these events can this can boston can
these topics so not this one
no way because i don't think we want a
nanny state but i think
that you know there's a difference
between those
uh the two guys in boston remember one
of them ran over his brother and killed
him in the shootout remember let's just
remember that
you know family family ties there baby
the i think what this is going to bring
up i'm going to be more aware of my
neighbors
and if i got a neighbor that's on the
friends it's not that i'm going to turn
them in it's like
wait what's going on here and i would
hope it leads to an america that's not
like a nanny state spying on your
neighbors but is aware of the people in
your life and is aware of things
and people can get help and i think
we'll prevent
you know some of things like this those
two guys in boston they were radicalized
students this was a like a hard plan
this guy seems like he was a lonely
weird kook over time
that took a horrible big step i think
tom question
question for you yeah question for you
guys okay so you remember that one movie
with tom
tom cruise that uh uh is arresting
people on future crimes what was the
name of the movie
uh minority report right do you think
we're ever gonna
get to a point where one can
based on searches you're making for
example if i go on google
okay and i'm searching how to make a
bomb
and i go and do searches like that for
one day two days three days how to make
a bomb to explode a building how to make
a bomb
do you think there's any any day anytime
soon that we'll get to a point
where there's gonna be a trigger to have
somebody come in
you know see why is this guy searching
these kinds of what can be done for
people like this to be prevented can
this be prevented
100 percent i mean nashville is a
beautiful city man this is i lived there
for a couple years so
how can you prevent this stuff from i
mean think about it did we think a year
ago that if you tweet something out
that it could be censored okay so even
in this past
year we've seen where if you do
something online there's repercussions
right if you start talking about bombs
or radical groups or i hate
the fbi or things like that you would
think that they would
you know be able to intercept this
especially if you couple that with he
went down and bought 50 000 pounds of
fertilizer right i mean that's usually a
bad mix
to make a bomb but the fbi said this guy
wasn't even on their radar screen
they didn't even know about him so you
can have a lone wolf like this
who's tactical who's weird who's crazy
i want to see what's going on with this
29 year old executive in la
i mean she already deleted all her
social media so
there's some sort of tie-in with her in
this quack from from
nashville that blew up second street but
it's
sometimes just an infatuation for a
woman can make you do stupid things
well but without what i'm trying to my
question is more from a perspective of
you're big on technology you're a fan of
technology you're a believer in
technology we're talking about earlier
with aws doing 22 million dollars and
q3 not 12 million dollars q 300 million
12 12 billion and q3
yeah and monster about to pass up some
of these other guys which we'll talk
about here in a minute
but do you think there will be a time
where we will have a technology
that's going to say be careful this guy
is scoring
in a 80 percentile that he's about to
dot dot
where action can be taken to prevent
behaviors like this
do you think we'll ever get to that
point we're in the baby stage of it
right now because the united states
secret service does this all the time
and they are they scan they have analyst
groups they have
they have a ton of technology that's
going out there looking at the
inflammatory statements and see if there
is
develops a person of interest to go
pre-interview
secret service will knock on your door
and do an interview um you can
you know go look up you know secret
service interviews secret service spot
interviews
field interviews there is a non-armed
side of the treasury department that was
working on counterfeiting and everything
like that of the treasury department
that is out there doing it so in a small
way it's happening now
where they're trying to be you use ai
and other things to say
should we knock on somebody's door and
go check them out before they do
something so in a small way it's
happening today
what what i think is the technology is
accelerating and i think it's
accelerating
and i think that you know what
if you're a little bit more of a
conspiracy theorist you know
you have all these anti-trust hearings
everybody's getting pulled except reid
hastings in front
google twitter facebook they all end up
in front of congress in these anti-trust
hearings
those simple deals they'll be made right
i'll tell you what you know we're going
to
suspend this hearing but this is what we
need we need access to this we need
access to that
and the government will have access to
it and they'll have their own think
tanks and stuff so
i think we're seeing it starting today
and it's only getting bigger i think
you're right
i i'm sure they're so far ahead of it
already and i have no problem with it
you know if you think that's an invasion
of the pr
of your uh privacy stop talking about
building bombs online then
i think if you're doing that and you
create that sort of red flag the
government should come knocking on your
door and you know here's the next
question can they send a drone over you
and take you out
if you're a real big threat like we do
with terrorists you know around the
world
um but yes you went straight from like
progress to
freaking middle east you know hey
permission to take a guy out
tom you went all the way to the end so i
did yes
you did i kind of did fast forward that
a little bit how many of you that are
listening to this right now would be
comfortable
if we were to get to a point where
technology's watching people's behavior
online where it's not necessarily a
facebook watches you talk about the
furniture that you want to buy next
thing you know 70 furniture ads come up
you're like wait a minute
i didn't even touch my phone these ads
come up but this time around
you're having a conversation you're
sitting with somebody talking about i'd
love to bomb this
such and such place or blow this place
up it leads to triggering
a federally funded organization that
comes out to want to investigate to see
why did you say that and why was that
come
would you be comfortable with that if
you're listening to this would you be
comfortable with the government
because remember fbi was an idea why
don't we come up with the federal bureau
investigation what is it here's what it
does
cia was an idea a lot of these
organizations are ideas
trump just came out with the new uh the
space uh what does he call it space
force
right something like that space force if
i would have told you 10 years ago space
force you would have thought it's a
hollywood movie but it's actually a real
thing
space force right would people come be
comfortable with us coming up with an
organization that actually studies your
behavior
and you could get arrested for
potentially a future crime you may
commit
don't forget homeland security right
homeland security is brand new
bush yep brand new spook november of uh
is when they came up brand new and by
the way if you want to think about
surveillance
that's the guys that would have all the
permissions
you know we're doing this to keep
america safe listen to the listen to
what they say about the virus right pat
we're doing this we're doing the
lockdown so you could be safe and people
buy into it
you know who else oh no we're doing
homeland security we're doing all these
things into your background
so you could be safe would you be
comfortable with that
would you be comfortable with what i
just said kyle would you be okay with
that it's like minority report yeah
would you be okay with that
you wouldn't be no sam because because a
part of the power would be abused right
absolutely i always go too far sam
correct are you in the same place as
kyle are you also in the same place
you know people say things sometimes out
of anger frustration
yeah a mental crime is not the same as a
physical crime
well have you ever gone into a fight
with a middle eastern
you see the things they'll say i swear
to god say that again my bomb this place
like
every middle eastern would be arrested
in glendale because when the fight
breaks out
they'll say i'm gonna bomb this
restaurant and you know people would be
but that's a good point by the way i'll
take the opposite view i got no problem
with it
you have no i got no problem at all
because i'll tell you why i got a better
chance of getting blown up by some
psycho
by getting killed then i have you're
totally cool
i'm cool with it because i'm not gonna
build a bomb
i'm not going to talk about it on social
media so i want the idiots that are
going to do it to be investigated you
know who else should be investigated the
neighbors that come out the next day and
say oh he seemed normal
oh he was such a nice guy investigate
them because they're stupid
if they can't see some of these clues
that this this
jerk down the block or on the cul-de-sac
has an rv and there's a ticking noise
coming out of it for the last three
weeks
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye